Over the last few years,
organic food has spread like
wildfire despite higher prices.
Buying organic is turning from an
alternative into a moral and social
responsibility.
Organic food is supposedly healthier,
more natural and more ethical,
but what do we even mean
when we say organic?
There's no global consensus,
so different regions have different
definitions and rules and general organic
food is farmed without GMO seeds,
synthetic fertilizers or
synthetic pesticides. Instead,
organic farmers use more traditional
ways of producing food like crop rotation
and use organic fertilizers
such as compost or manure.
While the motivation to buy
organic food is clearly noble,
is it actually effective or just
another costly trend we can skip without
feeling guilty?
Is Organic Food Healthier?
One idea associated with organic crops
is that their natural cultivation as
supposed to make them more
nutritious and healthier. Indeed,
several studies found that organic
foods contain more antioxidants.
Plants produce them as a
sort of homemade pesticide.
Organic plants seem to have
to work a little harder.
While regular plants have
plenty of help from humans.
Antioxidants are believed to
have some health benefits,
although scientists are still on
the fence about them. In general,
we have no idea if and how exactly they
help us or how much produce you'd have
to eat to absorb a certain amount.
What about organic being more nutritious?
Well,
the evidence is mixed.
Some studies found that organic food can
have slightly higher concentrations of
vitamin C and omega three fatty acids,
while others did not find
significant differences. Overall,
the mixed evidence suggests that there
are only small differences in nutritional
value,
so from the science available so far,
it doesn't look like organic food
has significant health benefits.
What we do know is that eating fruit and
veggies in general is good for you and
most of us don't do that enough.
Eating veggies is more important for
your health than how they were produced.
Is Organic food more natural people
don't only buy organic to get extra
vitamins,
but to avoid something toxic.
Artificial pesticides and fertilizers
and indeed several studies so that that
actually is less pesticide
residue on organic projects.
But here's where things get complicated.
Less pesticide does not mean none at all.
While pesticides are supposed to be a
last resort in organic farming than not
forbidden.
Most organic pesticides are natural
toxins like vegetable oils, potash, soap,
sulfa or copper sulfates, but there
are synthetic substances as well.
What's the difference between
organic and regular pesticides?
Not so a lot actually.
Organic pesticides are not necessarily
safer than conventional ones.
Toxic is toxic.
New Mass refer substances manufactured
or derived from nature. In fact,
in the case of copper cell face
often used on organic apples,
the organic pesticide of choice is
actually more harmful to humans.
The toxicity of any substance depends on
its concentration and your exposure to
it,
not if it's natural or not.
There are few reasons studies about how
our current level of pesticide exposure
affects our longterm health.
The 2018 study from France associated
never eating organic food with a higher
risk of certain cancers.
This study was criticized a lot,
though the participants reported
their dietary habits themselves.
While no actual tests of pesticide
levels in their bodies were done.
Complicating things even more.
A Danish study from 2018 found that the
danger from pesticides for an adult with
seminar to drinking a glass
of wine every three months,
the pesticides on your vegetables
are nothing to lose sleep over.
Despite this, we should continue to
demand strict standards for our food.
All pesticides are regulated and tested
very strictly in the EU and the US.
Every year thousands of food
samples are screened for pesticides.
The majority of samples have no residues
or just a fraction of the tolerance
level.
Right now,
contamination from bacteria and fungus
is much more dangerous and on this front
the risk is the same bit
organic or regular food.
Is Organic food better
for the environment?
In 2017 a Meta analysis looked at organic
farming in detail and analyzed organic
and regular foods from over 700
production sources and their impact on
categories like greenhouse gas emissions,
energy consumption and land needs.
The result, no production method is
clearly better for the environment.
Organic systems use less
energy than conventional ones,
but have similar greenhouse gas emissions.
Organic farms use less pesticide but
need much more land to produce the same
amount of crop.
These mixed results.
We're also confirmed by our report
from the Swedish food agency.
Organic and regular were equal.
In most regards,
the biggest difference was land use
and here are conventional farming,
clearly one and econ toxicity where
organic farming has a clear advantage.
So according to these results,
conventional farming actually has a
little bit less impact on the environment
compared to organic.
The bottom line is organic isn't superior
to regular produce as far as we know,
but organic agriculture also has
an impact at a broader level.
Demand is rising constantly and the
struggle to supply the market can lead to
production methods that are
less sustainable than other
ways. Spain, for example,
gross,
tons of regular and organic vegetables
destined for export in vast greenhouse
areas which use a lot of energy and
have other environmental impacts such as
significantly higher
greenhouse gas emissions.
And because growing demand can't
be covered by domestic production,
the global trade and organic
foods is also increasing.
As supply chains get more and more complex
to make all kinds of foods available
in organic quality shoring,
organic quality standards and
regulations gets ever more difficult.
This has led to incidences of fraud where
conventional food was labeled and sold
as expensive organic projects,
but organic versus conventional food
isn't even an objective discussion.
Organic is not simply a production
method for many, it's an ideology.
Buying organic feels right.
People want to do the correct thing for
the health of their children and the
wellbeing of the planet,
but our instinct is to think of organic
as good and conventional as bad can get
in the way of making the
most reasonable decision.
The solution could be to stop seeing
organic and conventional farming as
irreconcilable.
They both have pros and cons and
the best way to produce healthy food
efficiently would be a combination of
their best features and ask for your
personal shopping. What foods you should
buy depends on what you expect from it.
If you simply want to eat healthily,
we should buy more fruits and veggies
of any kind, not necessarily organic.
If your concern is for the environment
than simply buying organic,
we'll solve this problem for you.
The easiest option is to buy
local food that's in season.
Basically seasonal is the true organic.
To sum up,
an organic label is a
manufacturing notice,
not a security certificate or
a silver bullet for your diet.
What you eat is much more
important than how it's produced.
Production is very important for our
animations though we make them with a lot
of love and care and the best thing
is you can learn how to do them.
Coats [inaudible] joined skill shat a
favorite online net and community for
creators. With the three part
series of two d animation classes,
skillshare offers more than 25,000
classes on everything from film writing,
design and technology
from skilled experts.
The premium membership gives you
unlimited access for only $10 a month,
but we got you a treat the first 1000
people to use the link in the description.
Get that two months for free.
So to kick off 2019 if you want to give
animation of try and breathe life into
our characters or learn something else
to fuel your creativity or even Korea,
now you can.